y
[Música]
muy baja participación en la polémica
consulta popular impulsada por el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador promovida inicialmente como una
herramienta para juzgar a ex presidentes
solo fueron a votar 6.5 de los 93
millones de convocados cuando se
requería una participación de 37
millones para que este resultado fuera
vinculante
el presidente de afganistán culpa al
abrupto retiro de las tropas de eeuu por
el grave deterioro de la seguridad en el
país debido al avance del grupo talibán
sin embargo el gobierno afgano asegura
tener un plan de seguridad para
controlar la situación en seis meses
washington anunció que ampliará la
admisión de ciudadanos afganos como
refugiados
y a dos días de cumplirse un año de la
devastadora explosión en el puerto de
beirut en líbano en france 24 iniciamos
una serie de reportajes y hoy les
contaremos el duelo de la familia de
case móvil a un empleado portuario que
jamás regresó a casa tras el estallido
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco y como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en méxico donde la histórica y polémica
consulta popular impulsada por el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
para juzgar principalmente a los ex
presidentes por corrupción tuvo una
participación de sólo el 7% lejos del 40
necesario para que el resultado fuera
vinculante sin embargo la opción del cip
ha razón con un rango de entre 80 y 9.4
y 96.3 por ciento de los votos muy por
encima del no que estuvo entre el 1.4 y
1.6 por ciento según proyecciones del
instituto nacional electoral que hoy
dará a conocer los resultados
definitivos sólo fueron a votar 6.5 de
los 93 millones de convocados cuando se
requería una participación de 37
millones desde el partido gobernante
morena aseguran que el proceso fue todo
un éxito
creo que no debemos basar la
calificación del ejercicio de hoy a
partir del número de gente que participe
porque me parece que es un gran logro es
un día histórico y para la democracia
mexicana la primera consulta en la
historia la primera vez que ejercemos
este derecho constitucional vamos ahora
a brasil y miles de personas se
manifestaron en varias ciudades
exigiendo cambios al sistema electrónico
de votación vigente en el país desde
1996 los seguidores del presidente de
yair bolsonaro aseguran sin pruebas que
el voto electrónico abre las puertas a
fraude y piden que se implemente el
complemento del voto impreso auditable
el informe de juan fernando el vídeo
el voto electrónico en brasil en la mira
de los seguidores del presidente
bolsonaro aseguran que el actual sistema
de votación electrónico en brásil abre
las puertas al fraude electoral y exigen
cambios
queremos votos que sean controlados para
parar los fraudes en brásil
no sabemos dónde van estos votos es por
esto que estamos aquí para ayudar a
nuestro presidente evolucionar o quién
está a la cabeza de un buen gobierno
siguiendo los deseos del presidente
piden el voto impreso auditable una
herramienta que según dicen daría mayor
transparencia al proceso electoral en
caso titular no es sólo un propósito de
apoyar al presidente pero también por un
voto que pueda ser auditable y que todos
queramos esto es una muestra de
honestidad de parte del país y del
pueblo brasileño
en brasilia fue proyectado un vídeo en
pantalla gigante con un mensaje el
presidente evolucionar quien aseguró que
no se realizarán elecciones en 2022 si
no son limpias y democráticas para los
analistas el dirigente de extrema
derecha está allanando un terreno ante
una posible derrota en los próximos
comicios en los que buscará la
reelección tal como lo hizo donald trump
en eeuu aunque todavía no ha anunciado
oficialmente una candidatura las
encuestas dan una amplia ventaja al
expresidente luiz inácio lula da silva
en una eventual segunda vuelta
el presidente de afganistán ayer ráfaga
ni culpó del rápido deterioro de la
situación de seguridad en su país a lo
que calificó como un abrupto retiro de
las tropas de eeuu sin embargo el
gobierno afgano asegura tener un plan de
seguridad para controlar la situación en
seis meses los talibanes continúan
ganando terreno en el país actualmente
asedian tres capitales provinciales
estados unidos por su parte anunció que
ampliará la admisión de ciudadanos
afganos que podrán instalarse en la
unión americana como refugiados
la razón de nuestra situación actual fue
que se tomó una decisión repentina del
retiro de las tropas internacionales y
le dije al presidente de eeuu que
respetó su decisión porque era su
decisión pero sabía que tendría
consecuencias y la gestión de estos
riesgos se dejara en manos de los
afganos
y este 4 de agosto se cumplirá un año de
la devastadora explosión en el puerto de
beirut en líbano un hecho que dejó más
de 200 muertos y 6.000 heridos y el cual
un país sumido en una profunda crisis
aún no se recupera en france24 iniciamos
hoy una serie de reportajes este lunes
comenzamos con el duelo de la familia de
casen modula un empleado o portuario que
jamás regresó a casa tras del estallido
ambrosi es un barrio los suburbios del
sur de beirut
aquí es donde creció que hacen mawla
este empleado portuario perdió la vida
el 4 de agosto del 2020 cuando 2.700
toneladas de nitrato de amonio arrasaron
parte de la capital libanesa
su padre joseph recuerda aquella
terrible noche que pasó buscando a su
hijo
recorrimos los hospitales fui a ver a
los heridos estaba en las morgues
incluso examinar restos humanos para ver
si eran los restos de mi hijo no deseo
que nadie vea lo que dije oferten de su
estado con jaula bajada de su fe casán
tenía 26 años el día de la tragedia a su
madre amalia sólo le quedan algunas
fotos como recuerdo
recuerdo a mi hijo cuando era pequeño lo
abrazaba le cantaba para que se durmiera
lo alimentaba espero que dios no los
perdone ahora sus fotos están colgadas
por todas partes sólo quedan las fotos
de qué sirve tener solo fotos
howard la investigación sobre este
desastre sigue abierta pero joseph temí
que la clase política esté obstruyendo
el proceso
de mala fe
a todo diputado o ministro cuyo nombre
se mencione deberá comparecer y su
inmunidad deberá ser levantada desde el
momento en que sea interrogado aparecerá
no como testigo sino como acusa al fayed
contado un año después de las
explosiones y ustedes ya males viven con
el temor de nunca saber verdaderamente
qué pasó aseguran que seguirán luchando
a pesar de todo para que se haga
justicia para su hijo y para las demás
víctimas
cambiamos ahora información en francia
había surgido una nueva polémica en
torno al pase sanitario que entrara en
vigor el próximo 9 de agosto los
franceses vacunados en el extranjero se
quejaban de los problemas que tendrían
para conseguir el código qr que
certificará estar vacunado ahora el
gobierno dio luz verde a la
simplificación de este proceso pero
veamos entonces el informe de rodrigo se
da no con más detalles
un sencillo código qr que certifique la
vacunación algo sencillo de conseguir
para los franceses vacunados en
territorio nacional pero un dolor de
cabeza para los expatriados vacunados en
el extranjero esta realidad ha cambiado
a partir de esta semana los franceses
que viven fuera de francia y se
vacunaron con vacunas aprobadas en la
unión europea o sus equivalentes podrán
enviar por correo electrónico su
comprobante de vacunación para recibir
su código qr a partir del 9 de agosto
este código será obligatorio para
acceder a muchos lugares tras la entrada
en vigor del pase sanitario muchos
franceses han salido a la calle por
considerar que coarta las libertades
estoy aquí por nuestras libertades
nuestras libertades fundamentales que
son el derecho a decidir y especialmente
en aquello que concierne a nuestra salud
elegir ser vacunado o no los expatriados
se quejaban también que era muy
complicado conseguirlo tras haber sido
vacunados en el exterior sin embargo
aquellos inoculados con una vacuna no
homologada por la unión europea seguirán
sin tener una solución
que para muchos sería aceptar todas las
vacunas validadas por la organización
mundial de la salud por el momento el
gobierno no se ha pronunciado al
respecto vamos ahora hasta japón polonia
emitió una visa humanitaria a la del
[__] rusa de 24 años de edad
christina así manos calla y le brindarán
todo el apoyo necesario esto un día
después de negarse a abordar un vuelo de
regreso a su país tras asegurar que su
equipo la llevó al aeropuerto en contra
de su voluntad
seman usca ya se encuentra actualmente
en la embajada de polonia en japón y
según el comité olímpico internacional
se encuentra segura y a salvo al zenit
tsarevets el esposo de la atleta entró a
ucrania aún no hay pronunciamiento del
gobierno de alexandr lukashenko por este
incidente
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 continuar con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día
[Música]